good evening apparently it's a party
every weekend that neighbors feel they
are forced to attend but they're not
invited to thanks for joining us here at
six I'm Denise Valdez I'm David charms a
wedding venue is leaving those living
around it not loving the impacts 8 news
now reporter Ryan Matthey explaining the
Dilemma
[Music]
worse up here Mark Freeland has problems
with the neighbors just a while away
even in the winter they'll bring out the
heat lamps and you'll still get
occasional parties in the winter and
then the heat in the summer doesn't tend
to stop them either yeah they're like
Stadium lights neighbors that Tracy C
says like to party when he's trying to
go to sleep the spotlights are right in
his window and he's just always
complaining
it's a party because that's their
business I've registered 90 decibels for
my balcony the Lotus house a wedding
venue in the city of Las Vegas that
directly borders a neighborhood those
camera shy and not say it's not just the
party there's a 10 pm curfew but the
cleanup afterwards they've been up until
2 A.M cleaning up but their problems not
everybody here shares other neighbors
say compared to the crime in the
building that once stood this is far
better the owner shared these photos of
the once abandoned in private property
that they and neighbors confirm once
hosted squatters an illegal activity
frequently the venue began hosting
weddings in 2020. in a statement owner
Lincoln Rogers says the city has never
intervened on their operations and that
they will work with surrounding
neighbors for a mutually beneficial
solution but these neighbors say despite
contacting City officials and the owners
directly the parties keep disturbing the
music you know it's like cardi B you
know like things you just don't want
your kids to hear not having the crime
of the teenagers breaking in there is
great
but it was a lot quieter I wouldn't say
they've done anything better certainly
not for us